- All right y'all, I'm still here
keeping up with my social
distancing with my family
here in Montana.
This hour thou we're gonna
be celebrating my new single,
I dare you.
That I actually got to record
in six different languages,
which was really a dream come true for me.
This song is about love in all it's forms,
in the face of adversity,
you know choosing to love instead of fear.
I'm proud that the singers
from all over the world
sang with me on this track.
I love all the different languages.
I actually listen to those
more than the english version.
But we're singing in
their native languages
and we're so excited that we actually
have them on Zoom today.
We have Blas from España.
We have Faouzia from Morocco.
We have Carolin from Germany,
and we also have Maya from Israel.
How Y'all doing?
- Hey Kelly!
- Well okay guys, we're
all here officially.
Blas like what are you
doing, like right now?
Like how are you handling the quarantine?
- Yeah, I'm good.
A few days before the stay-home
order I was visiting my mom
and I could not go back home to Madrid.
And here I am, I'm good.
I'm happy because I found myself again,
I can, I can see the, all the
pictures and it's beautiful.
- Awesome.
- Oh what about you Carolin?
What are you doing, in Germany?
How are you hanging?
- Yeah, I'm doing good,
I'm staying home of course.
And yeah, I'm trying to make
the best of the situation
we are all in.
- Yeah.
- Yeah and I try to focus on some stuff
that is left undone at home
like cleaning out my closet
(giggling) everything.
- Oh my God I have organized
everything. (laughing)
- Yeah, me too (laughing).
Yeah but, but most
importantly I have enough time
to write some songs for
my band, Glasperlenspiel.
I think it's,
- Yeah,
kind of good to stay
at home now, and yeah.
- All right, well what about you Faouzia,
what are you doing right now?
You're in Canada right?
- Yes, thankfully I've
been doing really well
and I've been keeping busy,
working around these conditions
and making a lot of music at home
and I even got to make
a music video from home.
Which was a new experience.
- Oh my God.
- And I've just been praying,
you know for all the lives lost
and I just hope--
- Yeah.
everybody's taking this seriously.
- All right well Maya, what's up with you?
How are you hanging?
- Well actually I'm now in a show,
(audio lost) like yours in Israel.
- Oh.
- We are shooting, right now.
- Wow.
- And I'm so excited,
that is not here you
know because it's you.
- Okay, I couldn't hear the
last bit but I love you.
But it's cutting out. (everyone laughing)
- So okay, so here's my question I choose.
You know the song is about
daring to love instead of fear.
So what's the most selfless thing
that someone has done for you
that really kind of stands out for you?
Blas you can go.
- A few days ago I remembered
that I had a problem
with on our computer here at home,
and I asked of course somebody
to help me on Instagram
and a boy sent me a direct message.
We were repairing that thing
together the whole day.
- What, a stranger?
- Yes, it was great.
Now I have a new friend and
a new computer. (laughing)
- That's so great,
what a nice thing.
- Yeah.
- Amazing.
- You just put it
on the internet and then
somebody helped you,
that's so cool.
- Yes.
- Well Carolin, what about you?
- Yeah, selfless is what
my mother did to me.
We went through some tough
times after my father left us
and yeah, she worked, she
was always working so hard
to make my dreams and wishes come true
and I'm so thankful for that
because she's the reason
why I had the chance
to become a musician and yeah,
without her I wouldn't be where I am now,
so I'm, yeah, I'm very thankful for that.
- That's so cool, we
have a very similar story
after you just said that.
So what about you Faouzia?
- Kind of the same thing
but both my parents have been like very,
obviously very selfless and I think that,
I think that the love of,
you know, your parents
or your parents or who ever it may be
and you know that they don't
expect anything in return.
It's like, kind of scary but
it's also a very pure feeling
and I honestly owe everything
to them and to my family.
- Your parents sound amazing,
I remember you talking
about them in the studio.
You're a very lucky kid, that's so cool.
- You're not a kid,
- Thank you.
You're just a kid to me
'cause I'm like so much older than you.
(laughing)
- I have a daughter
your age (mumbling) so.
(laughing)
But, Maya what about, what about you?
- Since I've been a mother it's,
it's amazing, it's like to
see a little person loves you,
just free love with no, even
in this horrible situation,
during Corona that all the kids are home
and they are suffering from, you know,
doing nothing or study at home,
he's just selfless, he's like:
"Okay Mommy, just here you
are, just for you to be happy."
And for me it's the most incredible thing
just to,
- Yeah.
- to appreciate free
love, you know, with no...
- No strings attached.
- I hope all the people
will be like this after this Corona.
- Yeah, well thank you guys so much.
The song is very meaningful for me
and the project is very meaningful for me.
And it's even more meaningful
that y'all elevated it so
much with your languages.